hey do you like watching videos of two
people trapped in an elevator for 40
minutes and absolutely nothing happens
then I have the movie for you who lose
down is the most disappointing film said
in an elevator since Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles
actually that's more entertaining down
is a claustrophobic horror about a young
woman who spoiler alert gets trapped in
an elevator with a deranged psychopath
and yes this movie is so insane that she
actually has sex with him because when
trapped in an elevator where you're
peeing in a bottle dying of thirst and
wondering if you'll make it out or not
you immediately want to have sex but
other than the fact that it takes a
whopping 40 minutes for something to
actually happen in this movie is that
the second half offers nothing original
or wholly entertaining to make up for
its lackluster first half down obviously
was the film set with severe budget
constraints with 90% of it taking place
in one location now this is fine as long
as it doesn't affect the story but downs
excruciatingly slow pace unbelievable
character choices and unimaginative
kills make this film dead on arrival
thanks for watching and this has been a
think story one minute review